lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
aprender a usar una calculadora gráfica
en particular la calculadora t
84 aunque si usan cualquier otra
calculadora gráfica de texas instruments
el funcionamiento será algo similar para
poder responder algunas preguntas
relacionadas con variables geométricas
tomo cartas de un mazo estándar hasta
que obtengo un rey este es un ejemplo
clásico de variables aleatorias
geométricas y es importante lo que dice
entre paréntesis reemplazó las cartas si
no obtengo un rey en vídeos anteriores
mencionamos que esto es importante
porque así no cambia la probabilidad de
éxito de cada ejecución definimos la
variable aleatoria geométrica x como el
número de cartas tomadas hasta obtener
un rey y reemplazamos las cartas si no
obtenemos un rey cuál es la probabilidad
de éxito para esta variable aleatoria
geométrica recuerden que las condiciones
para una variable aleatoria geométrica
es que no cambia la probabilidad de
éxito en cada ejecución en cada mazo de
cartas hay cuatro reyes en un total de
52 cartas
por lo que la probabilidad de sacar un
rey es de 4 entre 52 y esto es lo mismo
que 1 entre 13 la primera pregunta dice
cuál es la probabilidad de que necesite
tomar 5 cartas esta es la probabilidad
de que nuestra variable aleatoria
geométrica x sea igual a 5 ustedes
pueden calcular esto a mano pero el
objetivo del vídeo es aprender a usar la
calculadora gráfica para estas
operaciones hay una función llamada geo
medef que significa función de
distribución de probabilidad geométrica
a la que tenemos que indicar la
probabilidad de éxito para cualquier
ejecución 1 entre 13 después indicamos
el valor particular de la variable
aleatoria que queremos encontrar 5 noten
que si hacemos esto en un examen ap está
bien ya que podemos usar una calculadora
en el examen ap de estadística esta es
una de las razones por la cual lo
hacemos así es importante indicar que
esto es nuestra p y esto de aquí es
nuestra x para que quede claro de dónde
salió esta información que usamos en la
calculadora veamos a que es igual esto
la calculadora la función que nos
interesa la vamos a encontrar oprimiendo
segundo y distribución esta etiqueta
azul sobre este botón y si nos vamos al
final de la lista veremos que la
penúltima función es la que nos interesa
damos enter y escribimos el valor para p
que es la probabilidad de éxito para
cada ejecución 1 entre 13 y escribimos
que queremos la probabilidad de tomar 5
cartas damos enter y enter otra vez y
tenemos aproximadamente 0 puntos 0 56
veamos otra pregunta cuál es la
probabilidad de que tenga que tomar
menos de 10 cartas es la probabilidad de
que x sea menor que 10 o también es la
probabilidad de que x sea menor o igual
a 9 podría calcular la probabilidad de
que x sea igual a 1 más la probabilidad
de que x sea igual a 2 y así
sucesivamente hasta la probabilidad de
que x sea igual a 9 pero me voy a tardar
bastante aún cuando use esta función de
aquí pero afortunadamente existe una
función de distribución acumulativa
es la función g o mets edf que va a
tener los mismos argumentos la
probabilidad de éxito de una ejecución y
todas las probabilidades acumuladas
hasta la novena de ejecución sacamos de
nuevo la calculadora y lo hacemos
segundo distribución damos clic hacia
arriba y la última opción de la lista es
la función que nos interesa
damos enter y escribimos 1 entre 13
acumulado hasta obtener 9 incluyendo lo
damos enter y tenemos aproximadamente
51.3 por ciento o 0 punto 513 la última
pregunta es cuál es la probabilidad de
que tenga que tomar más de 12 cartas
pausa en el vídeo y traten de encontrar
la respuesta por su cuenta qué función
usarían en su calculadora y qué valores
le pondrían esta es la probabilidad de
que x sea mayor que 12 que es igual a 1
menos la probabilidad de que x sea menor
o igual a 12 y para esta parte podemos
usar la función de distribución
acumulada
1 - g o mets edf de 1 entre 13 hasta 12
incluye
a que será igual esto sacamos la
calculadora y de nuevo oprimimos segundo
distribución hacia arriba y elegimos la
función ponemos que queremos el
acumulado hasta 12 damos enter y
podríamos dar enter de nuevo pero
realmente queremos 1 menos este valor
ponemos 1 - respuesta que debe ser uno
menos este valor que es aproximadamente
igual a 38.3 por ciento o cero punto 383
y con esto terminamos